welcome to this video this is some a war
zone video he on chess cube it's um it's
a late join I'm seven minutes late to
this tournament and all right got a
point I'm seven minutes late in a 30
minutes tournament so it's going to be
tough to get something going but I'll
try anyway course not I want to play not
wrong oh this is annoying alright so I'm
late I'm late yeah so it will be
difficult to to make a make a good good
result but i'll try anyway
I actually wanted to to to do the the
walls on final yesterday but I didn't
manage I started the tournament but I am
at a friend coming over I'm kind of a
surprise visit so high i stopped the
video i mean real life is more important
than some online tournament ok so now
i'm trying to get something going in
this in this event and it's not much
going on it's probably going night to
see five and how do I proceed maybe
maybe i can i can do this and get some
imbalance in this position it doesn't
take okay please got done some weakness
on g3 not sure that i can now do
something about that but maybe yeah i'm
not i'm not sure what he's doing okay
now his son taking b7 i cannot cover it
but i have some some play here only
three
yeah I've got a good draw at least but
probably am I cannot cannot play for win
g5 is probably risky yeah too little
time awesome maybe there wasn't g5 maybe
I should have tried g5 but I don't think
it was really working ok very strong
position here not the kind of fly this
is annoying why do these people always
want to draw I don't don't get it I mean
I understand that they are afraid to
lose to the game but this isn't really
the way to play chess always try to make
some some drawers and probably the rook
belongs on e 1 ok let's correct this and
it will need to go H form preventing
preventing g5
yeah it probably wants to sack the
exchange out this is a good good idea
get rid of this the strong porn the
other night were so bad piece onto I'm
activated to f3 was my idea cannot go
are you five at the moment I'm still
attacking define maybe 9 h8 what this
one also Stephen even better ok so now I
must must take AG he can play Knight f6
I'm I needed to take what the but with
the other piece this so now i don't i
don't really understand this must win
for white I've got Queen g6 threatening
also an extra Lucas good enough i guess
you can fairly highly rated players
don't resign with the rook down I don't
get it it's simply simply useless for
that one for their own good I mean
okay yeah of course I'm just I'm just on
place 20-year I need to win games very
quickly now to get them even a slight
chance maybe the bank oh yeah this
doesn't doesn't look too bad getting
some nice pressure on the center he lost
this time with with them coming with the
night yeah it doesn't tell you cannot
protect brilliant be too now
I know that's 9075 to come
ok this was fairly quickly okay maybe
maybe you for isos quitter
yep like us fairly solid here but I got
95 ok this is some maybe into aggressive
really but I cannot cannot play some
slow maneuvering stuff ideas to take on
me five ok and then g5g six not just g5
looks like a pretty a pretty good good
position for white f5s may be a problem
not be 1696 is very annoying move gather
some really didn't work out open maybe
doesn't take on 95 I don't give it now
oh this lease was lucky
yeah okay 19 points yeah maybe something
like third place and so are within reach
yeah let's play and play the pills for a
change normally don't do that but it
sounds interesting this looks a lot like
a Sicilian now it should be six silly
trick okay I can't play ecigs maybe
maybe there is some there is some some
way to get the get this bag it was
wasn't planned of course son at least
I'm not a piece down
yeah it's a fairly fairly annoying
position wyd still upon up and his
active this Bishop 1b3 especially
especially problematic yeah it's a
problem f7 I cannot recover this only
with a terrible move like this but it's
an I don't I don't know how else maybe
wants to take but I cannot do anything
against this take on the edge
we are firmly and nothing nothing that I
can do it's a bit double check coming or
whatever not quite sure what this was
maybe he's winning anyway but the whole
Queen sacrifice was of course completely
unnecessary he was just winning with
normal news Oh clearly better let's say
now Black is just winning I think
yeah very lucky I could have just played
normal moves and and win the game
arrived I suppose oh this was a nice one
so second place some guy was seven out
of seven but I've got a ridiculous
ridiculous average of opponents okay and
I'm I was seven minutes down this is
also i mean this is Pope this is two
games down seven minutes down all right
so this is some maybe not the best
opening to hit to win quickly but
sometimes some you just get into this
and ask yourself why the heck did I did
didn't I play something more active but
ok this is a certain defined I'd c5 g3
coming ok not each force mysterious and
now the g5 is threatening winning the
the night the night is so really am what
ok not sure maybe he wants to play
seafoam and make some kind of gambit out
of this but I don't I don't really see
it okay extra piece yeah shutting
shutting out the bishop on be too
yeah black as a piece of Endor this
Bishop won't be too really as a fun
filippis
ah c'mon just resins with would help
enormously maybe even trying for for
first place but probably am this won't
happen this resignation checking the
Queen maybe maybe he didn't that doesn't
see it i mean sometimes those pawn moves
are okay sometimes you don't really
realize that that your piece is attacked
and i will win in about ten seconds
because he's down on time all right yeah
this was too slow i mean i'm down to
fourth place again maybe a really quick
one i'm not quite sure i think it's only
five minutes left
we are 96 maybe 96 and with extra piece
yeah probably i'll finish place five or
something while seven minutes down is
it's a bit too much but i wanted to play
some tournament of this type so I just
went for it okay I can just take this
hmm by that will this night doctor I
don't have some direct witnesses I'm
quite amazing maybe g3 and I on takes on
d3 I can take with the Queen also with
the idea Queen 94 check Heather still
keeps the peace problem yeah now it's an
extra Brooke
I don't have the counter here I'll knows
this thing just one minute one minute
going can we go Jaden it third place for
the moment with one minute left yeah
maybe one more game but in one minute
it's difficult yeah okay of course hey
this is f5s pretty bogus but one of the
very few possibilities to to squat on a
quick winner against the Italian game at
least sometimes I will exchange down for
not much um yeah but to be five and c2
is hanging some
yeah I'm it stupid of course I needed to
play much much quicker to even get a
chance to finish the game but okay
didn't I didn't do it okay so um this is
aborted and I actually make took place
it's not too bad with seven minutes 7
minutes down let's have a quick look at
the final standings I managed to play
nine games and yeah some guy was winning
with nine out of nine but also I had an
average of two thousand sixty or
something and this guy at 790 average so
um this is a huge huge difference
alright i hope you enjoyed it was a
pretty quick tournament but i wanted to
post some some more entertaining stuff
than some Syria things on the final day
of the year so I wish all of you a good
start into 2013 have some nicer
celebrations and fireworks if you like
that and yeah I'll be back in the next
year cheers and bye